c'est l'un des thèmes centraux de la
campagne des régionales la
désertification médicale pénurie de
dermatologues de dentiste
d'ophtalmologistes sans parler des
généralistes selon la rs 48 mille
professionnels de santé exerce pourtant
en région centre
mais ce n'est pas assez pour couvrir les
besoins
état des lieux avec lucas chopin la
touraine serait elle boudé par les
médecins nous nous sommes rendus dans le
lochois pour vous demander si votre
généraliste est difficile à consulter
pas facile de prendre des rendez vous
c'est très compliqué il faut prendre au
moins des rendez-vous 15 jours voire
trois semaines à l'avancé
côté spécialistes le bilan est le même
il fallait qu'on écrive une lettre de
motivation pour aller voir notre hôpital
à anost allemand totalement ça c'est un
problème assez récurrent ou la non on
n'a rien du tout enfin ils prennent pas
de nouveaux clients donc
on n'a personne en effet plusieurs zones
du nord et du sud de l'indre et loire
seraient sous dotées en médecins et le
département compterait au moins quatre
déserts médicaux
c'est à dire des lieux où le nombre de
consultations en médecine générale par
an et par habitant est inférieur à 2,5
ou la première pharmacie est à plus de
10 minutes de route et où le premier
réflecteurs de médecine d'urgence et à
plus de 30 minutes dans les grandes
villes comme tour l'accès aux médecins
est plus facile pour autant le docteur
crémière tire la sonnette d'alarmé sur
le non remplacement des médecins à la
retraite en 2019 nous avons réalisé une
cartographie qui montrait que 60 % des
médecins généralistes exercer dans des
cabinets seul et avec une population
vieillissante puisque 45% de ses
médecins généralistes avaient plus de 60
ans on sait que les jeunes médecins ne
reprendront pas ou ne reprenne pas ses
cabinets médicaux
aujourd'hui la question de la couverture
médicale fait partie des principaux
enjeux de la campagne des régionales